it's great to welcome to the program
today michael kinch who is associate
vice chancellor at washington university
in st louis and also author of between
hope and fear which is a history of
vaccines
it's so great to have you on today
thanks the opportunity
so we could start in so many different
places but let's let's maybe start with
something that's a
big topic of discussion right now um
we've seen
sort of a different numbers stated about
what the goal should be in terms of the
percentage of of americans or or of
global citizens but maybe we'll start
with americans that
need to be vaccinated in order for the
u.s to approximate what would be called
herd immunity and of course there's a
number of input factors that determine
what this number should be how
contagious
something is uh how effective the
vaccines are and all of these other
things
what's what are the sort of the most
important things we should be thinking
about now in terms of
the variance in terms of vaccine
hesitancy all of these different input
factors
for if there is this this one number
that we should be looking at as
as the sort of threshold yes
and herd immunity is a term that has
actually been
misidentified and misused particularly
by the previous administration and in a
nutshell it's the likelihood that if
you're someone who is susceptible let's
say you were a cancer patient
who had chemotherapy that knocked down
your immune system what is the
likelihood that you will encounter
someone
in your vicinity that might infect you
and that number for
sarskav 2 the current source of the
pandemic
has been creeping upwards it started at
about 70 percent and it looks like today
it's probably between 80 and 85 percent
in part because these new variants the
british variant and the south african
variant not to mention a brazilian
variant that hasn't gotten as much press
are far more communicative so i think we
need to be shooting for 85 percent and
from a realistic standpoint that means
that we need to have
probably 90 to 95 percent of the
population protected
because again some people will have had
cancer therapy
rheumatoid arthritis treatment they're
simply old
very old or very young and they may be
immunized but the immunization may not
take
and so we're going to have to go in
excess of that 80 to 85 percent number
in order to assure that we
finally get this virus behind us now
this this may be
uh a silly question but
i've not heard it addressed head-on
necessarily when we talk about these
numbers i presume we're talking about
the entire population
if you are not including people below a
certain age at least
initially don't we really need a hundred
percent of eligible adults because there
are so many people
under 18 or 16 which are the ages that
the pfizer and modern vaccines
respectively have been tested on
don't we really need every adult
vaccinated
we do and essentially again that 85
number alone means that we need that the
vaccines are being tested
in pediatric populations but we don't
have the data yet
right and so every adult in order to
protect your children and your
grandchildren really needs to be
vaccinated soon and as you mentioned
it's not just here in the us
it's around the world because when you
look at it
as we've seen we have variants coming
out of south africa
and other countries and that means that
someone in one country or a population
in one country that decides not to be
vaccinated could actually jeopardize the
rest of the planet
on on today's program one of the things
we looked at
was uh a new study that looked at the
current level of vaccine hesitancy in
the american population the the good top
line news is that
the 60 65 percent hesitancy of may 2020
has
been reduced dramatically it's that now
down according to this latest study
about a third of the country when you
slice and dice different groups
three groups that are particularly or
disproportionately vaccine hesitant when
it comes to
this vaccination are
among political lines republicans among
racial lines black americans
and among educational lines those
without a college degree
four different reasons these three
groups seem to be hesitant of the
vaccine for different reasons
what historically have been some of the
most effective ways to get more buy-in
to mass vaccination campaigns
i think there are two things one is that
we need to be 100 transparent both in
what we know
and what we don't know we're not here to
sell a used car we're here to get past
the pandemic
and so i think that we need to convey
when there is information that we don't
know about
we need to convey that but we also need
to convey what we do know
and we need to stop rumors there have
been rumors that are completely
unsubstantiated about
causing lack of female fertility or lack
of male fertility and
many other things but we also need to
respect that there are certain
populations of people
for example uh black americans that were
subjected for example to the tuskegee
experiments
right and that means that they're
hesitant about many different
standardized medical procedures
and we need to then explain to them here
is what we know about it and why
you're not being an experimental subject
but this is important and that gets to
the second thing we can do
to minimize the anti-vaxx movement and
that
is to people it's been shown will be
more amenable to being vaccinated as
someone that they knew
was vaccinated and if it went well and
so the more that we get into those
populations the better it should turn
out
the um one of the uh
concerns i have and i'm wondering
whether you share it
is that there are many articles that
from my perspective
are underselling the benefits of in
particular the two vaccines that are
approved
right now and sometimes you will see
maybe not headlines but like
sub-headlines that will say even when
vaccinated
nobody can do anything differently
everything has to remain the same for a
very long time
and when you sometimes get into the
details or look at the blogs of
immunologists as an example
you will actually see much more
interesting information like listen
there is going to be some risk no matter
what but
a small group of vaccinated adults ten
days past
dose number two uh is at very low risk
to do an indoor gathering in particular
if everybody works from home you know
but
more sort of like meat on the bone about
there really are some differences and
this is a game changer and it will be
more of one as more people get
vaccinated
do you think my concern is is warranted
about the underselling of the vaccines
it is although again we don't want to
come across to selling a used car
right but i think you look at it these
vaccines are truly miraculous
the the magnitude of efficacy and
frankly safety as well
is far beyond what any of us thought a
year ago we would be able to achieve
especially within this time frame and i
would say
it's better than the apollo mission that
being said
we are underselling it and i think that
the proper way to address this what you
just mentioned which is very valid
is to say look we don't yet know
after you're vaccinated whether you
might be able to communicate
virus to others and we want to
communicate to people the last thing
that you want to do
is to unintentionally infect your
grandparents
your children your grandchildren sure
and so just to be safe
let's keep up those safety measures
until we have established herd immunity
and let's be clear what herd immunity
really means and i think most reasonable
people
will say oh if i'm protecting my
neighbors by doing this
that that's a great reason to do it not
that it's this onerous thing that we
have to continue to do
you were talking about the republican
pushback to vaccination
this is simply a continuation of the
denial that the pandemic was real the
denial that the masks
affect are effective and we have to get
past that and say look
independent of what your political views
are here's what the science tells us
what uh is the best way for someone
to um accurately sort of parse as you
talk about
so many rumors every single day there's
something the modern vaccine doesn't
work against the south african variant
oh it does but it just
is more borderline in terms of the
immunity versus being more robust
against the uk variant and oh well maybe
that's not true
uh we need to get to one level of herd
immunity versus another and then the
next day we find out oh the number is
actually different
for the average person particularly
people not like me who do this for a
living but people who have other jobs
where they can't follow this stuff
necessarily that that closely
what's the best way to stay up on what
the sort of top line realities are about
cases about deaths about vaccination
treatment etc
well now that the centers for disease
control and prevention
is under capable hands again i think
that you can go back to trusting them
frankly this we had the best public
health group on the planet
until the the this pandemic broke out
and they lost a lot of their credibility
and i frankly was telling people don't
listen to cdc because they weren't
giving the right information
but i would say if you had one go-to
reliable place it would be the cdc
otherwise don't google go
for example to mayo clinic or go to
whatever your local hospital has to say
look what they
have to say google and twitter
i mean one of the amazing things is that
if you look at the anti-vaxx movement
not just for this
pandemic but mmr and other vaccines
it is discomforting to know that about
85 to 90 percent
of the tweets that are anti-vaxx are
coming from russian troll farms and all
they are doing is really undermining and
their intent is to undermine belief in
authorities
and so i have not naive belief in
authorities but especially the cdc it's
turned itself around just in the past
few weeks
still got a lot of room to make up but
go to the major universities
other places that are not making money
or
profiting in any way from this for the
most part the pharma companies have
actually been surprisingly transparent
there have been some exceptions and i've
been a big critic of the exceptions
and we need to be critics of the
exceptions and but i would say that that
most people so far have come together
and been mostly responsible
when it comes to vaccines per day when
joe biden was
just days from being sworn in he was
talking about a million a day for a
hundred days
of course at the time the approved
vaccines are
are two doses meaning you're talking
about vaccinating 50 million people
we're now
hopefully getting closer to the approval
of the jnj
vaccine which will be a one dose and
then there's potentially more
more vaccines coming um when when you're
looking at this i mean it's it seems to
me that with a third vaccine
two and a half to three million doses a
day total
is is reasonable which seems like it
would be a major accomplishment but
we're still talking about months there
in the best of cases
until everybody can get vaccinated what
sort of numbers are you looking at
i mean i think the the the two key
numbers to remember
are 350 million americans right which
if we forget the jnj vaccine for a
minute that means 700 million doses
which is a lot
and this is a brand new technology but
then the other number is seven and a
half billion humans
which then means 15 billion doses and
again this isn't over
until it's completely over now i believe
in hope
that the jnj vaccine is likely to be
approved based on on what we've seen
right um its efficacy numbers are again
very impressive they're not quite up to
the mrna vaccine
numbers but at least it could get
someone some
transient protection if you will and and
future studies can determine well maybe
someone who got one vaccine will need a
boost of another
but i the the most remarkable thing
about the vaccine numbers
is not necessarily just the magnitude of
efficacy which is
exceeding at this point 95 and based on
the israeli study it may be closer to
99.5
right but it's the fact that the disease
severity is greatly reduced and people
frankly are not dying or getting severe
disease and that's where we want to be
if you're stuck with feeling bad for a
few days or getting a cold which most
grind of coronaviruses cause a cold
that's infinitely better than having to
be intubated and and
lord forbid pass away or have your
relatives do so so i would say the big
numbers now are we've got to ramp up
production
the need now the concern now is not
anti-vaxx the concern
is manufacturing and making sure that
the manufacturing quality still stays
high
and that's where again fda has been very
consistent and fantastic about doing
that
there have been some some preprints
based in some cases almost on accidental
circumstances that have surfaced
which suggest and again i want to be
careful to make clear that we're talking
about something we're still learning
about which suggests that
in some cases if at the time that the
second dose would be given
you just kept waiting you would get a
very close
level of protection to what you get from
the second dose plus 7 to 14 days
is that an interesting path that you
think needs to be looked at in terms of
of possibly being able to expand the
number of people inoculated with the
vaccines we're expecting to have
if the data show it um i think that
we run a risk there was a there was
discussion about giving everybody one
shot
right and even if it falls outside the
window that was done in the clinical
trials
um giving them a later shot we just
frankly don't have the data to say
whether that's useful or not and the
situation we don't want to end up in
is that we give everyone one shot and
one shot turns out to be insufficient
and we have to start
and turn around and begin afresh right
now everyone needs to get two shots even
if you already had one
and we just don't that we have to be
guided by the data
um we the last administration was
frustrating because they didn't seem to
want to track any data
and this administration i think is open
to it but there's going to be pressure
to hit these artificial numbers i would
say 100 million in 100 days is great
all i care about is as many as can be
safely
done that's the number we need to get
and hopefully that'll be well in excess
of 100 million
no doubt about it yeah and 2 million
last saturday and 2 million last sunday
certainly are great great great numbers
to start
seeing we've been speaking with michael
kinch
author of between hope and fear a
history of vaccines
also associate vice chancellor at
washington university in st
louis uh such a pleasure having you on i
really appreciate your time
thank you so much